Headless Viacom Java Hipness EEMA Vida
Resort und doch stoppen Sie den Skiclub hier in
Berlin
[ __ ] Khanubis es ist unhörbar toid
sofortiger Intellektueller und auf der heißen Seite
Wüsten Yolo Gay Richard Sennett danke
Ihnen in der staatlichen Dimension des zentralen wissenschaftlichen Denkens
und verzeihen Sie uns die kapitale
Landenge der Hordika, wenn auch  Schlank
wollte den ersten zu Hause
nennen Mitteltöne Erwähne Bob gesund für Ruhe darin
Danke
Yatta Felix der Frosch Zusammenstoß zu Beginn Bus
ist beschädigt Wer weiß
[Gelächter] Auf
diese Frage habe ich keine
einfache Antwort, aber in meiner  Ich
habe mir hauptsächlich angesehen, wie Menschen im
Konstrukt für sich selbst leben, und
nicht, was ihre Biologie ist, und vielleicht
wissen Sie heute, dass
mit künstlicher Intelligenz andere
Wege zur Rückkehr zum Biologischen immer weniger wichtig sein werden, aber
das ist nicht meine Welt,
ja, Saison sozial  Gelegenheit Vergänglichkeit
stickig Gummiband ist ein weicher Fäustlinge
erwähnt oft passieren Festungen von
Antigua und dies ist Buch, auch wenn sie
flexibel Männer Darin b  ahattin sehen staubig
quartic bleibt gut verliere nicht ein UKW-
system einmal erwähnt in einer leine kaput
mart wolken es ist schwer zu wissen ich denke
es ist noch schlimmer als die situation, die
ich beschrieben habe Vieles, was vor
zwanzig Jahren geschah, war ein Mann, der unterdrückte
Mann oder Frau, die Mann unterdrückt, oder welcher
Mann, der Frau unterdrückt, wie auch immer Sie sagen wollen,
dass wir jetzt am Beginn von
etwas stehen, wo Maschinen wirklich
Menschen beherrschen können, und ich glaube nicht, dass
der Begriff der Automatisierung in unserem politischen Diskurs überhaupt eine
Rolle spielt  Was wir unserem Arbeitsleben antun müssen,
wird wirklich diskutiert, und ich habe
dieses Buch kürzlich noch einmal gelesen, und wie schlau von mir
[Gelächter],
aber ich kannte nicht die Hälfte davon, wenn Sie es
wissen, aber die Vorstellung, dass Menschen
überflüssig sein können, dass sie gerecht sind  ein paar
Hände oder eine Funktion, dass es keine
menschlichen Beziehungen gibt, es ist etwas
, dem wir uns in Zukunft wirklich stellen müssen,
und es ist auf eine Weise zu
obskur, als dass die Politik gut damit umgehen könnte,
weil es einfacher ist, sich auf
bekannte Probleme zu konzentrieren  Zum Beispiel, ob
Einwanderer den Einheimischen Jobs wegnehmen werden, ah,
dann sich auf die Tatsache zu konzentrieren, dass ihr Hauptgrund
überhaupt keine Arbeit ist
Es ist nicht sehr einfach, gut
durchzudenken, was passiert, wenn ein Drittel der
Bevölkerung nicht arbeiten muss. Diese
Person kommt in dieses Team, das wir in unserem
Bite no Devon auf Survivor
mr verwendet haben.  mateen nehmen jede ärgerlichkeit von north
ave schicke frage es ist normal,
auf diese wesen und buddha flexible
bild zu hören und ich habe englische augen, dass es
die korrosion von kamelen sein wird, dass es sagt,
dass einige hahn staubwedel
eistees sind jetzt pflichten auf die  Hellenes Rhizome
über Vertrauenswürdigkeit, die eine eigenständige
Persönlichkeit in Großbritannien und London ist,
können Sand als eine Legierung betrachten
haben
eine Art Weg, der ihr
Gefühl dafür organisiert, ob es sinnvoll ist,
sogar Menschen in sehr niedrigen Jobs zu arbeiten, von denen
Sie wissen, dass ihre Kinder
in einer Wirtschaft, in der
es keine Karrieren mehr gibt, so etwas gedeihen werden, aber nur
Sie wissen Bits  von Jobs Serienarbeit Sie
haben keinen Weg Sie haben keine
Erzählung Sagen Sie, eine Sache zu lernen und
dann 10 Jahre später etwas
Größeres zu lernen, und das ist es, was
ich mit dem Corro meine  sion von Charakteren
, von denen es ein Gefühl gibt, wenn die Zeit
im Kapitalismus kürzer wird, wird das Gefühl der Menschen
für ihre eigene Zeit immer
weniger zu einer Erzählung, bis eine Art halbe,
bevor ich für Sie eine muslimische Alice
County Lady Langbogen-Entrindungsbefehl unterschreibe,
Lima und doch  Abschaum und Senior Dosmo wissen, dass
einige von uns aufhören, gefeuert zu werden. Ah,
du bist ein Optimist. Ja, hast du vor
, in zehn Jahren Bäcker zu werden,
nicht in deinem? Ich glaube nicht, aber das
Problem mit diesem System sind die
Menschen  die am mobilsten von Jobs sind -
Jobs, die in der Lage sind,
als Elite von einer Sache zur anderen zu wechseln, also haben Sie
für mehr Mittelklasse-Leute wie
uns einen Zusammenfluss von nicht langfristiger Arbeit
in jetzt mit Automatisierung mit immer
weniger  Arbeit, und das ist keine Vision der
Gelegenheit, also möchte ich, dass sich die
Leute wirklich darauf konzentrieren
, sehr einfache Dinge zu tun, wie
Leute für Service zu belohnen, wenn Sie ein überdurchschnittlicher
Fahrer sind und vier Jahre lang fahren,
sollten Sie eine Belohnung bekommen  für Don  Dass
es in der Arbeitswelt nur sehr wenige Belohnungen für
Anstrengung gibt, ist alles, was Sie wissen. Können Sie
diesen Job machen? Könnte es jemand besser oder
billiger machen? All diese Dinge
Meiner
steigt nicht aus und fühlt sich nicht an und es ist kein
Feld und Feld
Cello stand noch war
abgenommen und oft feucht und auf Abba in
Human Yaran hier drüben Handel mit einem Arahant
Eigene zwei unanständigste letzte Runde zu
Hause sein für wütend soll entkommen Zugehörigkeit
wie bekommt Howard Besuch ist ganz
oben nie wie ich denke ich '
Ich habe mich nie damit abgefunden, wenn
ich mein Leben damit leben müsste,
wenn mir diese Verletzung nicht passiert
wäre, wäre ich Musikerin, und ich habe darüber
nachgedacht, ich bin froh, dass ich meine Bücher geschrieben habe,
aber seit du  stellte mir diese
persönliche Frage,
es ist nicht s  Etwas, das ich jemals
zurückgelassen habe, aber Sie wissen,
dass es etwas gab, das ein Unfall
körperlicher Art war, wissen Sie, das körperliche Drama, von
dem ich in der Arbeitswelt spreche,
ist etwas,
das ein Design für immer kürzere Arbeit ist
für ein Design für immer mehr
Unsicherheit, das ein
Produkt ist, Arbeit zu leisten und es
auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise zu finanzieren, also denke ich,
dass einige Aspekte davon besser
lösbar sind, wissen Sie, es ist etwas anderes. Ich meine,
meine Geschichte ist erbärmlich und  Sie wissen, ich fühle mich
schrecklich für mich selbst, aber es ist nicht
die normale Geschichte, die seine Klasse tut, einige
hören auf, eine Travestie in so flexiblen
Zeichen zu sein, wie die meisten
Shahla Schnecke auf Schnecke einer Woche auf
Überlebender Ausdruck meiner Mutter
Musikplappern wie die Maja ja vida Musik  Severan
Vida Eifersucht Tank jetzt HIPAA-Musik jetzt
Krankenhaus-Themenmusik Nun, Sie wissen
eigentlich, dass ich in meiner Menge meiner soziologischen
Texte auf meine musikalische Erfahrung zurückgegriffen habe,
um Dinge wie „Wie kooperieren Menschen
in Cha  Bernsteinmusik, das ist
alles, was wir tun, wenn wir proben, wenn wir nicht
mit den anderen Spielern kooperieren, ist es ein
Durcheinander, und du kannst der umwerfendste
Virtuose sein, und es war nicht so, dass die Musik
schrecklich sein wird, also schrieb ich das Buch über
Rußlachs I  von ich mache viele von euch
, sie sind so billig, dass man konnte Ich habe
so viele Exemplare hier gesehen, aber ich habe viel die
Erfahrung gemacht, dass Musikmusiker zusammenarbeiten müssen,
selbst wenn Sie mit einem
Solisten spielen, mit dem großen Orchester, das
Sie haben müssen  Hören Sie, und was
mich daran besonders interessierte, war, wie
sehr diese Zusammenarbeit, wie wir sagen,
kontextabhängig ist, das heißt, wenn Sie und
ich Ravel-Violine und Cello
spielen würden, würden wir jetzt mit
ihren Augenbrauen kommunizieren, es gab kleine Gesten
Wir würden uns nicht sagen,
was das bedeutet, was Sie hier tun möchten,
und es schien mir,
dass diese Art von informeller, nonverbaler
Zusammenarbeit
in der normalen Arbeitswelt wichtig zu verstehen war und dass es sehr
schwierig war, per E-Mail zusammenzuarbeiten  für  Zum
Beispiel, und weil du die
körperlichen Gesten des anderen nicht
gut siehst, bist du in Bezug
auf den Raum, den sie einnehmen, nicht mit ihnen verwandt,
während ich meine, dass dies eine sehr grundlegende
Sache für alle darstellenden Künstler ist, bei denen
ich physisch in Beziehung zu dir bin  Es war
früher eine sehr grundlegende Sache in
Workshops, aber es ist schwierig, dies online zu tun
, so dass diese Art von
kontextabhängigem Lernen, körperliche Reaktion oder
Beziehung zu anderen Menschen, schwierig ist.
Eckpunkte sind und Antworten auf Skin
Minds sind ich Musik Ciaran mmm Mia und
Töpfchen  und sirup komm und zahl den
dienst der ausrichtung noch gar nicht nein mein
charakter ist kaum unverbesserlich und
ich mache einen witz darüber aber es ist wahr das
du weißt das wir die zusammenarbeit
zu sehr personalisiert haben ich hatte oft die erfahrung und
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch  Die Zuschauer haben die
Erfahrung, mit Leuten zu arbeiten,
die sie nicht mögen, und sie wissen, dass sie
in ihrem Job kein Freund von jemand anderem sind
, deshalb denke ich, dass es wichtig ist, dass
die Arbeitswelt etwas Besonderes ist  Wo
die Arbeit der Zusammenarbeit an sich
etwas ist, auf das sich die Leute konzentrieren,
anstatt mit wem sie zusammenarbeiten, mm-hmm,
und Musik, da gibt es eine sehr spezifische Sache
, die Sie wissen, wenn Sie
jede Woche mit Orchestern spielen, haben Sie ein
neues Set  Kollegen jede Woche, und
es muss Rituale geben, wie man
ihnen zuhört, sie hören einem zu und so
weiter, professionelle Musiker verstehen, dass es
in der normalen Arbeitswelt nicht so einfach ist
, mit Fremden zu arbeiten, Sie wissen
, deshalb in diesem Buch und in  das buch
könnte der handwerker ich weiß nicht wie
das auf deutsch heißt und
buckel ihr wisst das ist so eine art hunger yeah
yeah yeah der kunstfetisch typ
hat einen gefälschten ausweis reingebracht victoria bussarde ja
klar ich sag dir was das für ein buch ist
Der Anfang von Killer G of Books über
Homo Faber über das Machen von Dingen und das
Hunderterbuch handelte davon, was wir lernen,
was die Beziehung zwischen der
Hand und dem Gehirn ist. Wieder eine sehr musikalische Idee, aber
es geht auch im Allgemeinen um uns  wissen, dass
viele der lernenden Menschen das ist die
Art von menschlichem Tier, das auf die Welt zurückkommt,
wir denken, wir denken,
physisch mm-hmm,
wir sind keine Cartesianer, und das zweite Buch
in diesem Buch ist Sousa Minar, aber es war,
wie es ist  mit anderen Menschen zu arbeiten, und
das habe ich Ihnen gerade beschrieben
, und das dritte ist, wie Sie die
Umgebungen gestalten, in denen Sie
mit anderen plötzlich aufhören zu reden
gehärtet wie gewöhnliche AHA gequetschte fette Katze
über Satan's ist Argan verdammt - Tasman
etwas Frauenanus hilft Köpermolch am
wenigsten guter Mann
böse diese sind alle durch den Iran gerissen
sind beißen dies ist ein eigener und verarbeiteter werden
Sie fantastisch, denken Sie nur daran, der Amanda
McMartin-Korb für  Laurens Artie
geht in bestimmten und bestimmten Arten
von Arbeit verloren und es geht sowohl an Maschinen
als auch an das, was man einen Ansturm auf
den Grund nennt, der darin besteht, Leute zu finden, die
eine Aufgabe zum billigsten Preis erledigen, aber ich würde es
tun  Ich kann nicht allgemein sagen, dass die Idee
, gute Arbeit um ihrer selbst willen zu machen,
etwas ist, das die Leute nicht mehr
interessiert  Industriebäckerei, und obwohl
es mechanische Arbeit ist, gibt es Möglichkeiten, wie
sie darüber nachdenken, wie
sie aus dieser Arbeit Befriedigung ziehen können, nicht zu
viel
Scheiße zu
bauen  Sie sind besser, wenn
sie denken, dass ihr Chef
inkompetent ist, sie sind alle eine Reihe von
Einstellungen, die Sie kennen, die Autorität herausfordern
und so weiter, die die Leute dazu bringen, zu denken, dass
ich das gut kann, und ich denke, das ist ein
Grundbedürfnis des Menschen, also wenn die
Invasion  Chops Akitas herzhaft für den einen
oder das Erstaunen Herz ist ein Alt,
und es ist so, dass die Vorstellung, dass es
egal ist, wie gut ich diesen Job mache,
etwas ist, das sich in die Bereiche
der niederen Dienstarbeit bewegt  Zum Beispiel, wenn
Sie eine Spracherkennungssoftware haben, die
orientiert, ob ein Operator
zu einem Job kommt, Leute, die mit
Spracherkennungssoftware arbeiten, oder
es sind sozusagen Diener, aber als mein
Forschungsteam sie untersuchte,
waren sie sehr, sehr entfremdet für ihre
arbeiten viele Leute, die eine manuelle Dienstleistungsarbeit
machen, im Gegenteil, es ist immer noch wichtig,
Arbeit um ihrer selbst willen zu tun, und in bestimmten
Berufen wissen Sie, dass Medizin sogar
lehrt, dass Arbeitsmoral immer noch da ist,
was ich nicht daran glaube,
dass es so ist  Es ist möglich, dass Menschen
viel Selbstachtung haben, wenn sie nicht arbeiten.
Darauf bin ich sehr stolz auf sie, und
deshalb denke ich, dass Sie Sozialsysteme kennen.
Das Wichtigste, was
sie tun können, ist, Menschen in Arbeit zu bringen. Ich bin  Ich
gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel dafür, wann das nicht
passiert, wenn Sie ein Migrant sind, dürfen Sie in den meisten
europäischen Ländern nicht arbeiten, bis Sie Ihre
Papiere haben, und
das ist ein unglaublicher Schlag für die meisten
Migranten, sie sind nichts wert  Wenn sie
es nicht können, können sie sich weder sich
selbst noch anderen beweisen, weil es
diese bürokratische Schwebe gibt, also gibt es
sehr praktische Dinge, die aus
diesem Panel folgen. Ich kann jetzt sehen, dass dies
die Konstante unseres Körpers ist, zu der Ralph bei der Agnes
hilft  Ein paar sehr einfache zuerst
ging er und Japan beendete eine Show, auch
dies ist das Hören mit dem Humvee, das ein
Geräusch von Einheiten ist, die das Visum machen,
weil diejenigen von Ihnen denken
, dass es erhöht ist, ihn nicht in Kinovorführungen zuzulassen,
sind im Grunde nicht einmal
oft  Jagd Zwerchfell getan ist getan
Computer Antenne in der Luft halb
rechts seit im Garten oder auf Türkisch
ein Maha Musik CS Englisch ein paar
Acetatscheiben sind zu betrachten, nachdem
ich nicht herunterkommen kann, um zu bestellen, ist dieses Jahr ich Name,
kompensiert Ihr Ohr intellektuell und
widme  Nein, es ist so, wenn ich den
ganzen Tag am Computer sitzen und schreiben müsste
,
würde ich
nicht gut schreiben
Schreiben und Lesen mit
Bleistift ist für einen Architekten genauso etwas wie Zeichnen.
Du denkst, ein Architekt denkt,
wenn er zeichnet, anders als er
denkt, wenn er ein CAD-Programm benutzt
Hand sogar die Widerstände in
der Hand sind, das ist die Art von mentaler
Verarbeitung, wo bin ich hier
, weißt du, was will ich wirklich
dorthin oder möchte ich dorthin gehen, es ist eine
viel experimentellere Sache,
und ich finde dasselbe beim Schreiben  Ich war
zufällig in Yahoo gebügelt und Sheikh
Saleh Aletan war die Theorie von Sheikh
Adnan Fellow Harden als Logon-Vater, aber
heiß war Fleisch, selbst wenn er die Hamas in Neuseeland verließ
Ich hatte Glück, weil der Schlaganfall, den ich hatte,
etwas war, das meine kognitiven
Fähigkeiten aufrechterhielt. Ich konnte immer noch denken, hey, seit
du mich gefragt hast, erzähle ich dir, was ich
wieder laufen lernen musste, musste ich
lernen, mit dem Stift zu schreiben  Das ist sehr,
sehr schwierig, und ich musste sprechen lernen.
Ich konnte irgendwie sprechen, aber nicht wirklich,
Sie können es. Ich meine, wenn Sie wissen, dass ein
Schlaganfall wirklich eine
aktive Chance ist, was mit dem Gehirn passiert,
also hatte ich Glück und  Weil ich irgendwie so
körperlich orientiert war, weißt du, ich
wusste, was zu tun war, zum Beispiel von der Musik,
ich wusste, was mit der Hand zu tun war,
weil Musiker einen
solchen Bogen so halten, und ich erinnerte mich, dass ich
meine, das habe ich getan  als ich vier
Jahre alt war, und es hat mir geholfen, darüber
nachzudenken, von hier zu so etwas zu gehen. Sehr
schwierig, denn es ist nicht so, dass man
bei einem Schlaganfall nicht weiß, was man tun soll, sondern dass
man es nicht kann, muss ich sagen  Beim
Wiedererlernen des Laufens lernte ich neu, Sie
wissen schon, ich habe viel über Städte gelesen, und ich
lernte den gesamten Bereich eines
Fußgängers nah und fern von unterdrückerischen
Menschen, neuen Menschenmassen, es ist ein Dummkopf, eine
Art erwachsenes Kind, und Sie lernen,
wie es geht  wieder durch die Umgebung zu navigieren
ist nicht, dass er h nicht sehen kann  Ich
denke, wenn sie sich drehen und das Team
ankommt, wissen Sie, dass sein Buch Karate dort ist
, wo sie das Waisenhaus braucht, das
sich in Spike in
London und New York befindet, das hier lange
Interesse am Herzen von Massey Hobbit hat, wenn
sie Miras Label-Vater sind  neue hektische
Vierer in Tokio und London und
Halsted in hier ist der
erwähnte Baumeister,
Masson würde entweder vom ausgerichteten Feld oder von V & T
essen  Eine Rezension eines
Interviewers war so romantisch, dass
Menschen nicht unter Menschenmassen leiden,
wenn Sie ein 75-jähriger Rentner wären, der in einem Altersheim lebt,
wo Sie jeden Tag 20 Schritte gehen
und ein oder zwei Menschen
sehen würden, die Sie lieben würden  Saat das ist eine
Art Leben du willst Straßen du willst nicht
auf dem Stuhl sitzen und
dahinvegetieren Ockman Pastor Heinrich zwei Prüfungen er sagte
Laban schnapp dir Scheiße Sakura hat ein Schwein aus
London Mann vielleicht sogar DC Wen Frauen
können keine Einstein werden  Ich bin
fast am Haus. Ich mache meine Kinder und
Enkelkinder, sie mögen es, außerhalb der
Stadt zu sein, und das ist wahrscheinlich
psychologisch okay, wie dort, aber Sie
wissen, ich kann es ein oder zwei Tage aushalten,
aber ich wollte etwas Ernsteres sagen
Über Menschenansammlungen und Sie haben mich
nach Schlaganfällen gefragt. Eines der interessanten
Dinge bei einem Schlaganfall ist, dass eine der
ersten Erfahrungen, die Sie machen, nicht darin besteht, wie
Sie mit Menschen aus Menschenmassen
um Sie herum umgehen, weil zu viele
Informationen für das
periphere Sehen eingehen  du gehst
oft und hast schwindel, also
hast du angst, in jemanden zu fallen, und
eines der dinge, die ich in diesem buch
beschrieben habe, ist, dass ich in berlin immer kontraste benutzt habe,
wenn ich in london als jüdin in
berlin als gymnasium war  Sie wissen, dass Sie
üben, diese Straße auf und ab zu gehen,
es ist eine schöne lange Straße, es gibt
viele Cafés, es gibt asiatisches Essen, das ich
verehre, aber was ich meine, ist eines der
interessanten Dinge, die ich nur tue, weil ich das
erwähne, dass eines der
int  Erstaunliche Dinge über die Genesung nach
einem Schlaganfall wissen Sie, wenn Sie sich erholen,
wenn Sie mit vielen anderen
Menschen zusammen sein können, weil Sie wissen, dass Ihr
Körper zuversichtlich ist, einer in der
Menge zu sein, die
Sie kennen, also ist das gegenwärtige Küste, aber wie
gesagt  Du bist schrecklich romantisch in Bezug auf
diese Menschen. Menschen brauchen Menschenmengen. Sie brauchen
die Stimulation von Menschen, die anders
sind als sie selbst. Sie brauchen keine Leere.
Ja, in der Einsamkeit, und wie wir von Lucretius wissen, ist die
Einsamkeit etwas, das
man in einem Spaltdesign schon in einer Art fühlen kann
sehr offen und ich trainierte bei
M le pas son kommen auf Ankush pornhub und
Deepika Intuition unter Artikel
erwähnt in unterbesetzt in einem
Arzthaus, aber verstehe kundan als uncool für einen
anderen Bergkrebs denkt, dass
deine Beilage so stoppt Tisch Easton und
Haken sehen selbst Tsakanikas Flugzeuge  ist in
visuell verpassten drei Paulista warnt davor,
wenn Thomas Gazellen sie oft beenden
, führt das Armand passieren führt mr.  Tomita Highs und
irrationale Absichten, die nicht
klingeln, ja, es ist schön,
weit weg von Zigaretten zu sein, du wirst nicht
auf Kentuckys Luftschacht fallen, es
macht das Englisch aus, das ich auf
dem Tipp sehe, bis er da ist
ihr Bruchrisiko und das
passiert in vielen Städten, dass wir
ihre Räume zerstören, in denen Menschen
, die anders sind, interagieren können. Ich
weiß nicht, wie es in Deutschland ist, aber
in den Vereinigten Staaten wissen wir, dass es
eine Korrelation gibt  Rassistisch zu werden ist,
dass man nicht viel Zeit mit
Menschen einer anderen Rasse verbringt, man war weit weg
von ihnen,
und wenn ich als Stadtplanerin arbeite
, interessiere ich mich für die
Art von Räumen, die Menschen auf eine
nicht bedrohliche Weise vermischen  wo sie nicht
miteinander reden müssen, aber
wieder im selben raum sind das mag
in deutschland trivial erscheinen, aber es ist in stark
segregierten
ländern wie den usa  In Großbritannien,
insbesondere in den Vereinigten Staaten
, verbringen rassistische Menschen sehr selten
viel Zeit mit anderen Rassen, also habe
ich versucht, in diesem Buch einige Strategien zu beschreiben,
um dies
sehr beiläufig und informell zu tun, wie eine
Technik in der  Buch, das ich
beschrieben habe, ist, wie man Schulen und
Gesundheitskliniken so plant, dass sie an den
Rändern zwischen zwei Gemeinden liegen und
nicht im Zentrum, und für Flüchtlinge war dies,
wie ich zuvor sagte, die
ganze Idee ist, dass sie sich durch Arbeit mischen sollten
mit Menschen, die keine Flüchtlinge sind,
also haben Sie absolut Recht. Ich meine, was
wir sehen, sind Städte, die
meiner Meinung nach geschlossener werden, ja,
getrennt, sie sind nicht wirklich Städte, und
die wirtschaftlichen Folgen sagen noch
etwas, aber ich gebe etwas  Ihre sehr lange
Antwortzeile ist wunderbar, die
wirtschaftliche Konsequenz davon ist
etwas, seit wir seit der
Zeit von Aristoteles wissen, dass, wenn Sie
verschiedene Arten von Menschen zusammenbringen,
Sie etwas erschaffen  Art von Synergien und
Konflikten und Kohäsion, die die
Wirtschaft eines Ortes erweitern und in London zum
Beispiel der robusteste Teil der
lokalen Wirtschaften in London diejenigen
sind, die sich gerade an den Rändern zwischen
verschiedenen Gemeinschaften befinden, wenn Sie in die
Mitte eines Muslims gehen  Gemeinschaft Diese
muslimische Gemeinschaft in East London, das
sind Orte, an denen nicht viel passiert,
aber wenn Sie die Aktivitäten sehen, bei denen die
Leute Geld verdienen, wo sie
handeln, wo sie Kunden
bekommen, ist alles am Rande, also die praktische
Strategie, die ich suche  In diesem Buch geht
es darum, wie wir diese Art von Porosität erzeugen,
mm-hmm, damit Menschen in Menschenmengen
mit Menschen sein können, die anders sind, die sie
vielleicht nicht kennen und sicherlich nicht mögen,
und ich denke, das ist eine gute Regel für den
Weltraum  regel für schulen sicherlich
eine gute regel in bezug auf das alter sie sagen ihnen noch
eine sache,
die mir in amsterdam nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wirklich aufgefallen ist
es gab einen
architekten namens aldo van eyck, der t  ook
hat Teile der Straßen weggenommen und daraus
kleine Teeny-Parks gemacht, ja, und es
waren Parks für Kinder zum Spielen, für alte
Leute zum Sitzen und für Märkte, die
Ränder dieser Parks hatten keine Zäune von der
Straße, und die Leute sagten, er sei das nicht
gefährlich für Kinder, sagte er, nein, sie
müssen lernen, in einer komplexen Umgebung zu leben.
Viele der älteren Holländer
, die in diesen Parks waren, waren dort, um zu
trinken, okay, also haben Sie Kinder, die
Verkehr spielen, vorbei an diesen älteren Leuten
mit Gin und Leuten, die einfach herumlaufen
Jeden Tag so etwas wie ein
Umfeld, das Menschen
kompetenter macht, mit Komplexität umzugehen und
gerechter zu werden, wenn man
etwas an die Grenze zwischen zwei ethnischen
Gemeinschaften stellt, werden kompetentere
Menschen endlich sagen, ich habe verloren, dass dies das ist, was
ich suche  Stolz und
dieser Abschluss von Ich bin eine staubige jüdische
Mission Essen und doch Konten von
Logikbefehlen sind Kummer für Raucherentwöhnung
Ich gebe zu, Tims Recht Sasha Tech unter Schock
eine Eiche zu presen  nt aus den Köpfen offen, oh
ja, sie sind gute Freunde in New
York, um Tops auf ihnen zu machen
Benutzer für diese besessen von unserem
verzweifelten Nest wie ein mauszerfallener
Latino hängen Nacht für sie den Übergang, den
ich sagte, seit Olympia-Star John
Gilmore kein Recht hat, seit Museum
einmal gesehen hat, ist diese winzige städtische
Plattform ein Opener oder Voodoo und Hokkien
basierend auf  Die Saison von Mia Geburtssohn
Brutus was auch immer existiert ein Vertrauen uns
die Twister Power Barmherzigkeit tut Dimension
Kontingent von Unterstützung wir mögen es formell
und Markham richten die Cajon und zierliche
Geisteskrankheit aus, in er hat
genau die Saison vor dem Ende, um mich
noch so anzuweisen  nicht sehen und vor allem
sagen, ja ja, ich teile diese Ansicht und
wo ist die Idee dahinter, dass
es keine Eins-zu-Eins-Beziehung
zwischen Form und Spaß gibt  Wenn Sie in
ein Opernhaus gehen und ein Arzt in der Nähe
ist,
ist ein Café geöffnet. Vielleicht können Sie
Ihre Nägel alle im selben Raum machen lassen, wenn
Sie gehen, oder wenn Sie nicht könnten, wenn Sie ein
Teenager sind, hängen Sie einfach ab, ohne es zu haben  für
alles, was man tut, schafft man einen Lebensraum, wenn
ein Opernhaus nur für die Oper ist, dann
schafft man eine Art toten Raum, und das
Geniale an dieser Erweiterung der Tate Modern war insbesondere,
dass viele
Dinge gleichzeitig passieren, das ist im
Jargon der Stadtplanung  Es ist ein Ort der Sünde con
Lluis, und wir machen sie nicht
sehr oft, man sieht sie im Zentrum von Städten,
wo sie tagsüber voller
Menschen sind und es sechs Uhr morgens kommt, und
ihre Ödlande, weil wir sie nicht
erschaffen  Synchronität
in der Zeit als Aufgabenlichter Ich habe zum ersten Mal
ein schmuddeliges letztes Jahr und eine Hälfte
anständige Pflanzen gelesen und den einzigen Streit, dass
sie ja gleichzeitig nicht
sequentiell sind, derson Granulat, und
hier kommt der Kapitalismus wieder ins
Bild, weil viel  des
Internationalen  y finanzierte Projekte in
Städten sind sehr eng korreliert Form
und Funktion Projekte in Bezug auf das
Geschäft Ich hatte einmal eine Ich werde sie nicht nennen,
aber ich hatte eine lange Diskussion mit
jemandem, der in Hongkong in Bürogebäude investierte,
und sie sagten, man
solle investieren  eine Schule da drin und sie
sagte, oh nein, du weißt, das ist ein erstklassiges
Gebäude, ich möchte nicht, dass ihre kleinen
Kinder darin herumlaufen, und ich fragte,
was daran falsch sei, sie sagte, niemand
würde für etwas bezahlen, das so
gemischt genutzt wird, und  das ist in den
chinesischen Städten in den Entwicklungsländern
in lateinamerikanischen Städten das ist, wenn
Dinge durch internationales Kapital finanziert werden
, das ist, was sie wollen, sie wollen
genau wissen, was sie kaufen, und
das ist der Tod einer Stadt, wenn Gelder
Zinsen und Sparmaßnahmen bringen, Okapi Gillison
ist nicht gegeben auf freiem Feld in Chicago
in einem Saloon sehe es lange unheimlich Alton
Varanasi verwundert und höre einen Motor das
Periskop Kommunist höre ein Motorpferd
ja er ist ein Mutasa ja durch dreh das
li auf  ne am Tatort Valluvar nahm zu
viel Geld auf und er half tatsächlich dabei, die Konten zu konfrontieren. Es
ist ein sehr aktives leichtes Motiv,
weil diese
Gefühle
um jeden Preis vermieden werden müssen, was ein
weiterer Teil der Rhetorik der
Anti-Immigranten-Stimmung ist  Es
wäre schwierig, mit diesen Leuten umzugehen,
weil Sie nicht wissen, wer sie sind, sie
sprechen nicht Ihre Sprache, sie haben
andere Erfahrungen gemacht, wie
schrecklich sie nicht Kopien von
Ihnen sind, das ist dumm und Sie wissen es  Das
Zeichen einer Art Vereinfachung und Erleichterung des
Lebens, die letztendlich
Menschen Schaden zufügt, endet in Santa's Can't
Durst und sie sehen einen unbesetzten
Schacht, in den wir hinabgestiegen sind, um zu überleben, und so
manifestieren sich diese Erbauer sogar als Aktivisten, um von Mutanten vollständig besessen zu werden  Auszeichnung, das war
nichkhun sogar das Auflegen der roten Ohren
auf Professor Keatings Taten, sogar von
der Warnung, dass ich Nulldiagramm bekomme,
gut, ich würde das Wort Übung nicht verwenden,
aber ich sa  id, was im
Bildungssystem passiert ist, dass wir
Schwierigkeiten nicht auf die Art und Weise untersuchen,
was gut ist, was gut ist. Ich gebe Ihnen ein
Beispiel dafür, dass wirklich intelligente
Kinder einen Test nicht so schnell wie
möglich absolvieren, weil sie  könnte von einer
falschen Antwort fasziniert sein, warum ist es falsch,
womit das mental verbunden ist, ist die Vorstellung, dass
es eine Beziehung zwischen
Problemlösung und Problemfindung gibt. Es ist ein
wesentlicher Aspekt guter Handwerkskunst,
dass Sie dies tun, wenn Sie Kinder testen,
geben Sie mir einfach die richtige Antwort  Sie haben nie danach
gefragt, was an etwas problematisch ist
, und ich unterrichte jetzt am MIT,
was eine ziemlich technologische
Umgebung ist, und was mich beeindruckt, sind
diese wirklich guten
Techniker, sie stellen diese Frage die
ganze Zeit die
ganze Zeit, was daran falsch ist oder
wie können wir es falsch machen
was schwierig ist wie können wir dies
schwierig machen seine art darüber nachzudenken
und es ist etwas, das ich erkenne, wenn ich
könnte bis zu meiner eigenen
kindheit  d Der Umgang mit Schwierigkeiten
war ein Weg zu überleben, nachdem
man normalerweise den mittleren Rahmen persönlich ignoriert,
wenn man versteht, dass Kundan auch ein Eindringling ist, der fassungslos ist, nur Maho, so schrecklich ist, dass er es so entsetzt findet, wenn sie
tatsächlich wie ich schießen, okay, nicht
wahr?  Schrecklich,
es finanziert sich gegenseitig in den Weihnachtsmann und
hört sich die wertvollen Gewebefüller von jemandem an
oder von den Strängen in ihrem Haus, die
im Frühjahr drohen. In DC-Bits erhalten Sie Fernsehmelodien,
die am Anfang des Ministers genug und schwer zu erwähnen sind.
Re verlässt uns und führt uns nicht in
Booba auf Süßigkeiten zählt Zitate Legierung Wendung
in meiner Fantasie Bidens Pass allein muss
aus dem Land der Dänen sein Kannst du den Raum in
Garmet Knock Bomb kennen? Ja, ich erzähle
besonders von Levinas, der
jemand ist, den ich kennen durfte
Am Ende seines Lebens hat er uns eine
sehr lange Reflexion überlassen. Hatte einen sehr
schwierigen Krieg. Zweiter Weltkrieg. Er hatte eine
lange Reflexion. Oh, da trug er die
ganze Zeit dieselbe Zeit. Das ist erstaunlich,
Martin Buber  Sie, der Dialog zwischen
ihnen, war dies das uns lieben, das
schrecklich schreckliche Zeiten durchmacht, darüber
nachgedacht, wie Menschen zusammenleben können, wie sie sich
miteinander identifizieren müssen, wie sie
jemanden respektieren können, der nicht versteht,
und seine Vorstellung von einem Nachbarn ist
jemand, der Sie ist  kann Seite an Seite
mit leben, ohne zu versuchen, die
Unterschiede
zwischen dir und ihm auszulöschen, und er hatte mit goober einen
sehr langen Streit, weil du weißt, dass
goober nach Israel ging, er lebte unter unserer
eigenen Art und er versuchte, das Buch mit dem Titel
II und du einen Versuch anzuschauen  worum es bei
intimität geht und um uns zu lieben
, das ist die frage war anders,
dass ein nachbar in seinen begriffen darüber hinausgeht
er sieht die welt nicht total an er sagte
das ist sein wort dafür er schaut auf
etwas das jenseits des totalen von
was ist  er kann sehen, dass er in seinen Händen halten kann
wie einen Globus und
etwas unendlicheres in dem Sinne, dass
es grenzenlos ist, und es gibt sehr
gute jüdische
Weisheit  aber es ist auch Weisheit, dass
du weißt, dass das eine ganz andere Art ist
, über den anderen nachzudenken, als zu denken,
dass du
die Unterschiede zwischen ihnen auslöschen willst. Ich sage dir
eine praktische Sache davon, denn für mich
weiß ich, dass ich Beratung mache  Für die Vereinten
Nationen und ein Klischee, dass die Arbeit bei
vielen Dingen der Vereinten Nationen läuft, ist, wie
Menschen einander besser verstehen können, wenn
sie sich in Konfliktsituationen befinden oder
so etwas. Das scheint mir
Babynahrung zu sein, Sie wissen, die Frage ist nicht,
wie  besser verstehen,
um zusammenzuleben, aber wie man zusammenleben kann,
ohne zu verstehen,
und deshalb sind viele unserer
Bemühungen zur Konfliktlösung in der Vergangenheit gescheitert,
jetzt werden die Menschen immer mehr 11 ASEAN
mm-hmm, das ist einfach, viele Salons sind
immer dafür, ein Fahrrad zu stehlen  es ist das
Haus mit einem R nicht Zhu lis pendens
eeschema und finde das wie wenn, es sei denn, es
verlangsamt mich Tina kürzlich Kumpel
Babybesitzer nicht Spezialität kaufen in V-Ausschnitt Kotflügel
ja wegen der Oberflächen und tun  ne
Lobby Shaffer kreativ Oberon's
Erica's ich gerade über jedem Hana Hana Visum
oder kein Hana Dopey also sind wir fertig fertig
sind nett huh nein ich glaube nicht an
Utopie
denke ich als praktische Angelegenheit und das
kommt wieder auf die Frage,
Dinge zu machen  Das, was wir wollen und deshalb heißt
dieses Buch Open City, was wir
wissen wollen, ist nicht, was der ideale
Plan ist, was die Lösung für ein Problem ist,
sondern welche verschiedenen Möglichkeiten
es gibt, mit einem Problem umzugehen, von
der Größe von Windows bis hin  Das Bauen einer
Straße zum Nachdenken über die
Territorien zwischen Menschen und das, was
wir in der Stadtplanung nicht hatten, wir hatten
diese Masterplanung, die die Masterplanung
der Meister ist, wissen Sie, und die
Alternative wird zu oft als das, was ein ist, umrahmt
alternative Vision, die
widerstehen wird, dass dies der falsche Weg ist,
über die Öffnung einer Stadt nachzudenken. Was
Sie tun möchten, ist, über viele Möglichkeiten nachzudenken
, die mit jeder guten und schlechten Vergangenheit möglich sind
, die Sie möglicherweise so in der Vergangenheit verfolgen möchten
Buch, was ich tue, ist, ich öffne fünf.
Ich stelle fünf Möglichkeiten vor,
spezielle oder soziale Probleme zu problematisieren
, die diese Beziehung öffnen
und Menschen eher zu Nachbarn als zu
engeren Zusammenrücken machen könnten,
und das ist das. Ich bin kein Idealist.
Ich denke nur, wir haben Sie bearbeitet  wissen,
es ist ein Prozess der Forschung Sackgassen und
Schwierigkeiten mr.  Jean seufzt, ja, es ist die
Zuschreibung an das Projekt unserer Heimat,
aber ich habe Demenz. Ich war Martha und
Kennedy. Ich sehe, das ist eine amerikanische
Revolution. August, Polen ist eine Quasi-Träne,
sie tun es weniger
Dateien ASCII-Attentäter Details totaler
Organist auf Wirtschaft und was hat das
Unmanifest gefragt, dass Sie den Schlüssel
zu Papieren und Wutstopps gegeben haben, dass ich 116
Meter bemerke, aber die Lustlosigkeit der Frauen
v62 Gericht, dass die beiden behaupten, dass meine
Kristallkugel sehr, sehr nah, aber ich sehr nah ist
Denken Sie für uns beide, das
Wichtigste ist, wie praktisch es
ist, den öffentlichen Bereich
über den Bereich des Konsums hinaus zu erweitern, das heißt
, den öffentlichen Bereich mit Aktivitäten zu füllen
, die jeder teilen muss, und den
Schlüssel zu den Papieren, die der Plan sind
Saskia und Iron Richard Burdette machten
vom Treffen der Vereinten Nationen eine Art und Weise, wie sie sich
wirklich nicht auf die Übel des
Kapitalismus konzentrierten, das ist alles klar,
aber was für eine Alternative in wh  Ich öffentliche
Räume werden immer komplexer und
das hat einen theoretischen Hintergrund, nämlich bei
der Theorie offener Systeme geht es darum
, die Dinge eher komplexer als
klar zu machen, und deshalb ist meine Kristallkugel
trübe, weil wir nicht
nach einer einzigen Antwort suchen sollten,
ja du  Wir wissen, dass wir nach Praktiken suchen sollten
, die uns auf Wege führen können, an die
wir nie gedacht haben.
Deshalb bin ich jetzt auch im Bereich der Arbeit tätig. Ich bin
so daran interessiert, eine Diskussion
darüber zu beginnen, was es bedeutet, zu sein
ohne Arbeit
weißt du, Harz, um zu sagen, wir sollten
jedem geben, wenn er arbeitslos ist, gibt
ihm Vorteile und so weiter, warum ist es
wichtig zu arbeiten, es ist dasselbe,
es ist eine Frage, und es ist eine schwierige Frage
, also ist das in dieser trüben
Kristallkugel  Was mir wirklich wichtig war
, ist, wie man eine Stadt öffnet,
die zu klären ist, die zu einfach ist, um
getrennte Bianca-Lehre zu machen, ja, Mazal-
Winkel und Kosten von 100 Meilen
Achteckkurs und Ferrari, wenn Tequila veröffentlicht wird  c
intellektuell Ich war eine intellektuelle
Einstellung, die im Nebel eingeschlossen war, auf dieser Seite,
Mann, bleibe lange, Name,
Ausdauer ist unsere Sünde, T, Sünde, T,
Haus, neues Haus, Wasser und 48, unermessliches
Recht, noch Zustand32
[Gelächter
] Nun, ich werde dir sagen, was mich beschäftigt
und als a  Student of Labor Ich interessiere mich dafür,
wie man Technologie einsetzt, damit Menschen
gedeihen und nicht erniedrigt oder
missbraucht werden, wie sie es von Facebook und
Google und so weiter sind, und sage insbesondere voraus,
wie man künstliche
Intelligenz einsetzt, damit Menschen nicht
am Arbeitsplatz missbraucht werden  Das war,
als cnz, dass ich endlich etwas gesehen habe, okay,
ja, ja, und ich wollte sagen, ich weiß nichts
über drei, aber die andere große Sache
, die mich beschäftigt hat, obwohl ich
nicht viel darüber geschrieben habe, aber
es ist etwas, an dem ich arbeite  Die UN
beschäftigte mich mit der Frage, was
die Beziehung zwischen Klimawandel und
urbaner Form ist, und eines Tages, wenn ich lange
genug lebe, werde ich ein Buch darüber schreiben,
denn das sind Sie wissen, in dem Jahrhundert sind
die Städte, die wir kennen, g
Aufgrund des Klimawandels werden es völlig
andere Umgebungen als die, die
wir jetzt haben. Das sind also die beiden. Es tut mir leid, dass
ich kein drittes für Sie habe, aber das sind
für mich persönlich die beiden großen Zukunft.
Kotaku, es sind keine schweren Zeiten, richtig  und ich bin
klimabündel in der fantasie angehalten,
anstatt sie anzufreunden, es ist wie wladimir davon
spricht, zu versuchen, sich zu entwirren,
und ankita beton, es sind viele dinge, die ich
meine, für einige städte ist es der meeresspiegel,
für andere ist es die zunehmende extremität
des wetters heiß kalt  Für viele Städte wird es die
so genannte
Wüstenbildung sein, d.h. ein Mangel an Grundwasser.
Es wird viele Formen annehmen, und
viele davon sind unvorhersehbare Prinzipien, von denen
wir wissen, dass es mehr
Stürme geben wird, aber wann und wo sie zuschlagen werden, ist
Etwas, das wir nicht vorhersagen können, und die städtische
Frage dazu ist, ob wir
mit diesem Klimawandel arbeiten, bei dem
wir größtenteils sowieso einen sehr schlechten Job machen,
sage ich, nicht, ich spreche nicht das Wort Trump,
aber für diese eine Sache  aber t  Dies ist eine
Katastrophe, die passieren wird, und die
Frage ist, wie Sie mit etwas umgehen
, das nicht gelöst werden kann,
etwas, das ein hartnäckiges und
schädliches Problem ist, und das ist einer der Gründe
, warum Sie wissen, dass ich nicht so interessiert bin
Politik gerade jetzt,
weil viele Politiker sie
wissen, dass es nicht auf dem Radar ist, es gibt dort keine
Abstimmungen, es wird ein komplexes Thema
und sie überlassen
es jemand anderem  Grenzen Sie wissen,
es ist so, ich denke, warum widerstehen Sie
der Kristallkugel-Sache ein bisschen, weil Sie,
was Sie wollen, eine Antwort haben, und es
gibt keine, das sind strukturelle
Probleme, es könnte hart für Sie sein.
Ich meine, ich bin nicht einmal  sie sauberer bundl
TT khatallah null nada Automaten sehen uns
Anästhesist kein Problema Candice Neil
Heinen Shores Design vermisst NT Miriam
erwähnt die 2p die sich wiederholende Arbeit
macht Ärger an einer Maschine und die
englische Polizei kann Zoe  Getnum
oder das Auto und was, ja, wir könnten gärtnern,
weißt du, es wäre wie der Garten
12 Stunden am Tag, sieben Tage die Woche,
wie würdest du dich dabei fühlen, ja, wie
wäre es, ein Bäcker zu sein?
Automaten, das sind schlechte
Gefühle, Muffin kann kein faules
Treffen treffen, ja, ich kann die Grenzen des
Vermögens der Autoschlossschwester bekommen, ja,
ja, ja, vielleicht ist das das
ultimative Problem mit dem kommunistischen Regime
, dass Freizeit als etwas angenommen
wird  Letztendlich ist es das, was
Menschen wollen und dass sie
nicht produktiv sind. Deshalb habe ich diesen
Homo Faber geschrieben, dass die Idee, vom Machen wegzukommen
, ebenso eine Fantasie ist, wenn
Sie wissen, dass der ältere Marx nicht geglaubt hat, dass
dies der frühe Mensch ist  Sie haben
Angst,
aber die Vorstellung, dass Sie
kein produktiver Mensch sein müssen, dass Sie
nicht arbeiten müssen, die Freizeit und das Vergnügen
werden Ihr Leben füllen, ist eine sehr sehr
kindische Sache und ich denke, es ist sehr
unbefriedigend für die Menschen  e Ich meine, stellen Sie sich vor,
wenn Sie sagen, Sie hätten davon eine Fantasie
und Sie könnten die Kindererziehung mechanisieren und automatisieren
, damit Sie sich nicht die
ganze Mühe machen müssten, dass Ihr Leben
unglaublich verarmt wäre, wissen Sie, also
ist es ein Problem und es ist ein Problem
beim Lernen, wie man mit diesen
technologischen Fähigkeiten oder
technologischen Katastrophen umgeht Richard Sennett
also Jesus Grab Sie haben Pamir
auf Schlüsselbeine bekommen, die leuchten müssen, damit Sie
denken und fühlen, und Hüte und Dunk, damit es
Ihnen gut geht, danke
[Musik]
Ihnen